we always love it when our own cooking
confidence coach
nettie bubbe is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment and today we're going back to
basics and we're going to talk about
some terms that i've heard before but i
have no idea what they mean well this
initiated this segment today was
initiated because last week when we were
doing lunar new year i said to rocky
we have to julienne the snow peas and i
thought she was going to drop on the
floor right so i said don't worry i'll
come back next time and we're going to
talk about julienning blanching
chiffonading and how to clean mushrooms
so we're going to start first right here
with the snow peas soap and we're doing
and the first thing well let's do this
hey siri set the timer for 45 seconds
because i was a little late okay
and what what black chickens and
counting
in everybody's house right now the
timers have been set before
exactly so blanching is basically
putting your vegetables into boiling
water i do this with a
chicory tray of vegetables and because
it gets the raw taste out we're going to
let them go and then as soon as it's it
the timer goes off we're going to
immerse them in and you know what this
is ice water ice bath ah now so all of a
sudden we've only got
is why we don't just say boil the
vegetables because this is the blanching
this is blanching right you don't really
want to boil them because they get too
soft but blanching gets them the exact
um crispness so you drop them in boiling
water for
approximately one minute and then
ice water right now and the ice water
does what the ice water shocks them yeah
and stops them from cooking so if you've
ever taken green beans out of a strainer
and just put them in a bowl they steam
on top of each other and they get
overdone overdone overdone and overdone
so is this traumatic for the green beans
you say it shocks them it shocks them it
keeps them from cooking right okay so
now they are the perfect temperature
serious digging here let's get rid of
that now let me show you how to julienne
so julianne do you know what the um
uh like how to describe that
i was more of a marianne guy myself
i like that so all right so what we're
going to do is we're going to cut it
basically julianna's match sticks so you
just cut down okay just like this
see that so could you julienne other
vegetables as well like carrots celery
fennel
and see how they're nice little
matchsticks oh nice okay there you go
okay let's talk about cleaning mushrooms
okay you ever cleaned them mushrooms
i've never cleaned them okay so first of
all never never never immerse your
mushrooms in water it absorbs the water
if you go and put them into a pan to
saute them they're going to be soggy and
you'll never get the water out so this
is a
brush a brush a mushroom brush did you
know there was a rocky there you go
that's another one long handle short
handle okay here's the mushroom what you
do is you take the brush and just look
at that do you see the dirt coming off
the top yeah actually and you're just if
you don't have a mushroom brush then you
take out the stem into the bowl if you
don't have a mushroom brush very easily
there you go take a wet paper towel and
then just wipe it with the wet paper
towel okay all done that's important to
do because
you don't want to throw mushrooms into
the pan and have dirt while you saute
your milk what's really cool about this
is that you started this four years ago
oh right right and and at that time i
mean you you didn't start off as an
expert you grew into this world exactly
so four years ago when you interviewed
me on the set here i was talking about
how the entire life of my children
growing up i tried to cook i wanted to
cook my kids cried every night my
husband complained that it was the same
thing every single night and
they insulted me and nowhere else except
for every night at dinner are you judged
yeah that's true and it was so bad of
course when my kids became teenagers
then they started talking about help
yeah then it was and i ran away from
home for three days so i know what it's
like
to
work through this pain point and that's
why i like to stick with the basics okay
so let me just show you this really
quickly with this is called chiffonade
okay this is basil now i just want to
tell you it must be very very very dry
in order to chiffonade basil so i always
wash right when i get home but if you
needed to use this really fast you wash
it okay you go outside because we're in
the desert and it's very dry and
basically you take your arm ready and
you just go like this
and come back into the house and it'll
be dry enough to shift that's the
advantage to living here in las vegas
exactly so just a few seconds left we're
going to chiffonade right here
which means ribbon this is your basil
and ribbon so you see that
very nice okay do we have time to ask
you what this is we don't actually but
tell me anyway it's a watermelon radish
and i'll just cut through this like this
and you'll see how beautiful it is
that's not it that's not beautiful okay
that's beautiful okay see that's how
well i know it but i've learned some new
things and i love that you simplify
everything it's always good thank you
kendall thanks so much check out nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com
we also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment rocky i am
taking notes over here you guys